欢迎各位收听今天这期百车圈说我是三刀。
今天这期节目呢，打开标题应该知道我要聊什么话题了。
最近一段时间呢，关于七年低利率贷款方案，也是连续好几天上了热搜。
很多的小伙伴也问我说三刀，你怎么看？
很多的一些朋友买车，现在看到这个七年期的低利率方案，应该讲新潮还是比较捧派的。
员先二三十万的新动员车，自己根本就买不起。
现在首付只要几万块钱，三四万四五万块钱啊。
那么月供就两千多块钱，就可以把车开走了。
那么也就是说它的门槛变得非常的低，但这个门槛低是用时间换来的。
因为原来的三年贷款，两年贷款，现在变成了七年贷款，对吧。
大家也知道现在有一些什么五年免息，但是七年跟五年比，那还要多出二十四期呢，对不对。
一年十二个月嘛，两年二十四期嘛。
所以很多人一看，这个门槛也很低，然后每个月的月供也很低。
所以他就觉得他能买得起，就是隐隐约约，就感觉好像我买这个车子没什么压力，
不就是七年嘛，每个月就两千多块钱。
那么他现在手上这台车呢，旧车啊，他感觉就不香了。
其实老粉丝都有印象，早年我也分析过这种超长的汽车贷款方案。
我曾经也说过，全国有一个非常大的经销商集团代理奔驰的嘛。
他们当时就推了一个十年期的奔驰的几个金融方案，它是上市企业嘛。
它有一个金融公司自己来做，那么同时呢，它还可以去结合，
比方说抵押带，包括消费带，它能把你之前首付款加上你的购置税，再加上你的保鲜，
甚至包括你的买它的装潢，以前买奔驰不是还要加一万两万的装好吗，
这些钱全部能给你带出来，所以这个事情当时影响也挺大的，
那么就导致肯定有很多坏账嘛，有些老板资金链就断掉了，
因为他想装啊，他想开个奔驰，然后这个有面子，大家没有钱，对不对，
所以当时几乎是零首付就可以把车开走了，
然后就每个月还还还不停的还，
但你想这一个车辆买回去，它可能是结合了两种贷款方式，
甚至结合了三种贷款方式，我都不知道它是怎么办下来的，
三种不同的银行，不同的贷款方式，
结果就每个月要不停的拆东西，想补习想之后就很多人就奔掉了嘛，
那么今天我们讲的这个七年期的低利率贷款方案，
这个方案呢，厂家也没有补钱，其实是有补贴一些资金在这里面了，
但是呢，你也不能说它很良心，因为一会我要展开来讲，
这里面套路还是非常多的，其实它给你出7年没给你出30年，
我觉得它已经算是良心了，就是仿态是30年期的对吧，
但是大家也知道一辆车是不可能开到30年的，
所以基本上给你一个什么7年的汽车贷款方案已经算是上线了，
那么今天这期节目呢，就给大家来一起分析分析，
这些七年期的低稀贷款方案背后到底有哪些不为人知的套路，
这到底是天上掉线饼，还是天上掉陷阱，
那么我们先说一说一夜之间，全网为什么都在讨论7年期的低稀贷款方案，
它是怎么来的，其实最开始是特斯拉在1月6号的时候宣布，
2026年1月31号之前去购买特斯拉猫豆三和猫豆外，
还有就是猫豆外L嘛，就可以享受超长7年期的超低稀的贷款方案，
那么海报里面当时写的清清楚楚，我们就说猫豆三跟猫豆外吧，
猫豆三是首付7.99万起，月供1918元，
猫豆外首付5.99万起，月供2263元，
所以你看你买量猫豆三每个月只要还1918，
买量猫豆外每个月只要还2263，
而且首付都很低，实际上7.99万我觉得它可以再低一点，
它可以比较说降到5万多块钱，
把2万块钱再分摊到7年期里面其实也多不了多少钱，
但是特斯拉相对还是比较克制的，
还是按7.99万起就是8万块钱的首付，
那么仅仅10天之后雷军就在直播间也公开宣布了，
他说2月28号之前你只要下定小米的预期，
那么也可以享受7年的低稀贷款方案，
那么首付只要4.99万起，月供2593块钱，
4.99万就明显，
你看我刚刚还说特斯拉是比较克制的，
那小米明显就不克制了嘛，
对吧，你首付7.99我首付就4.99，
你月供2263，我月供比你稍微高一点，
2593就说明这小米的车主的收入普遍。
应该还是比特斯拉车主要高一些的，
都300块钱嘛，对吧，
300也是多，
那么小米这边公布完之后，
仅跟着理想也宣布跟进了，
首付3.25万，
所以你看中国车企卷到什么程度了，
对吧，特斯拉7.99，
小米就4.99，
小米4.99,
理想就3.25，
3.25起,
然后就是首付，
月供2578块钱，
我第一名啊，
然后Mega和i8这两款车，
还提供了专属的贷款方案，
前三年给你面稀，
然后月供就低至2857块钱，
这两款车为什么会这样操作，
因为根据它的分析就这两款车的车主，
大部分都是企业主，
那么这两款车的它的单价有比较高，
所以它就给你一个贷款的额度比较大，
第二个周期比较长，
小米这笔资金我给你贴稀，
你拿去用，
因为讲起来是买车，
实际上你是从理想这里带了一笔钱，
当然了这个也不能叫带一笔钱，
就是少付了一笔钱嘛，
车你正常用，
但是你没把你账上的钱花出去，
对吧,
只是变成了月供，
那么两千多块钱，
对于很多老板来讲，
它是肯定能接收的嘛，
那么我一开始以为到了理想这边嘛，
基本上就差不多了，
对吧,
你后面肯定有人出7年期，
那不可能那么低嘛，
都已经三万两千五了，
我就不敢想象它难道说，
还能一万多嘛，
哎,
仅跟着小鹏就出了他的7年期的低息方案，
首付低至15%，
月供低至1355块钱，
我就把这茶给忘了，
就是小鹏的车它的单价是比较低的，
然后他把首付又调低到15%，
所以,
小鹏的Mona M03入门版案十一万九千八去算，
他15%,
相当于要付多少钱，
首付一万七千九百七，
你没有听错，
首付不到一万八，
你给他一万八，
他还找你三十块钱，
然后呢，
带款就是带十万块钱分八十四期，
所以每个月，
你算下来确确实实就是还一千三百五十五块钱，
我的天，
真的是，
就少买一个iPhone手机嘛，
对吧,
然后每个月还一千多，
很多人会觉得没有压力嘛，
所以小鹏这一波的销量，
我估计是又要往上冲一冲了，
那么很多人可能会想，
这没毛病啊，
入门的门槛变低了，
带款的周期虽然长一点，
但是月供的压力变小了，
厂家还提供各种贴息，
你怎么算都感觉这是福利啊，
这不就是变相的降价嘛，
好,
我们来具体算一算啊，
没错,
从某种意义上来讲，
这确实是变相的降价，
你比方说，
你拿特斯拉的这个方向来讲，
如果说厂家不贴息，
那么去买一辆特斯拉的Model Y后区的标去版，
指导价是二十六万三千五，
首付百分之十五，
那就是四万块钱左右，
带款就带二十二万四，
那么按照正常带款的，
这个折合联化利率来算的话，
应该是百分之四点六九，
这样的一个计算方式，
那么七年的带款要支付的利息差不多在四万左右，
而现在呢，
因为厂家贴息了，
所以它的折合联化利率相当于变成了一点三六，
它的总利息七年啊，
七年加在一起，
也就只有一万出头，
所以你看，
从四点六九变一点三六，
从四万左右变成一万出头，
那么前后一对比，
相当于厂家，
就给这辆车特斯拉Model Y的后区标去，
贴了差不多三万来块钱，
这就是特斯拉，
我们再举个例子，
比方说小米的预期，
小米预期的标准版，
它的售价是二十五点三五万，
那么在不加装任何这个选装的情况下，
它七年低期方案，
它们最低的首付就是四点九九万，
那么带款就带二十点三六万，
对吧,
你怎么算吧，
二十五点三五嘛，
那么带款平贪到八十四七，
每个月还款额度差不多是两千六百块钱，
那么一共需要支付多少利息呢，
挺好了，
七年时间啊，
总共支付的利息一点四二万，
那么如果说不用这个低息的方案正常带款的话，
那么每个月的还款额度会变成两千八，
利息的总额会超过三万五，
那么这样子一对比的话，
你就知道了，
就是小米的这样的一个，
就是低息的七年期的带款方案，
相当于能省两万多的利息，
对吧,
其他几家就不一个一个说了都差不多，
带款基本上在二十到二十五万上下，
它变相的补贴应该是在两到三万块钱，
那么这么看来的话是不是很划算啊，
如果说你觉得很划算，
你就准备上车了，
那我就告诉你，
你就上套了，
为什么，
因为这背后，
远比你想象的复杂的多，
那么接下来我就要好好地，
讲一讲今天节目的重点了，
一定要仔细听啊，
这为什么说它复杂，
千万千万，
你如果需要你就买，
如果你不需要，
千万不要碰，
这个叫做七年的低息带款方案，
那么我为什么会说复杂，
主要是因为目前这个七年低息带款方案，
市面上有两种模式是并存的，
你如果自己不会判断就非常容易被坑，
第一种模式是传统的车带，
第二种模式是融资租令，
也叫以租带购，
我曾经节目里面介绍过，
以租带购是什么意思啊，
我今天再展开来说一说，
那么这两种模式最主要的区别一共有五个方面，
第一个，
传统的车带大家都知道，
就是跟银行带款嘛，
对吧,
或者是这个车企跟合作的银行把钱带给你，
那么传统的车带，
车辆是属于你本人的，
也就是说那个绿色的本子，
就是车辆登记证书，
还有大家都很熟悉的行驶证，
这上面都是你的名字，
但是融资租令，
这个车辆是归属于租令公司的，
就是说你花了钱，
你交了刚刚所谓的首富，
实际上你是在租车，
这个车辆不属于你，
行驶证登记证书都是租令公司，
你是租用人，
那么这是第一点，
第二点，
传统的车带，
还清了带款，
对吧,
那么你就可以解衙，
解衙完你就可以自己去自由买卖，
或者说你把车子从这个城市去落户到其他城市，
去换换车牌都没有问题，
但是融资租令，
对不起，
融资租令，
比方说84期到期之后，
你还需要有一个叫买断过户的这么一个操作，
相当于这个车的原先不是你的名字呀，
那么买断过户之后，
你才能自由买卖，
而这个买断过户的过程当中，
第一个手续复杂，
第二个，
你还需要交一定的费用，
没有说，
就像银行那边说钱还清了，
直接去解个衙，
不用钱，
就直接就把这个登机讯书上面盖个掌就结束了，
没有那么简单，
因为这个车原本就不属于你，
你只是租用，
那么第三一点，
传统的车代是抵押贷款合同，
而融资租令是回租合同，
这一点的话我要详细跟大家讲一讲啊，
那么第四呢，
就是传统车代提前还款的话，
很多人是要提前还款的对吧，
提前还款通常，
要么就是给你谈好了是没有违约金的，
或者说它的违约金相对比较低，
那么融资租令对不起，
融资租令一般它不会去接受你提前还款，
你要如果提前还款违约金相当的高，
通常是剩余本金的3%，
甚至更高，
那么第五一个呢，
就是传统车代，
如果说你要是余期了，
主要就是影响一些真心，
它甚至还会有一些，
比方说这个叫什么宽限期，
但是这个融资租令啊，
如果说越贡你没有跟上，
那对不起，
要么就是罚，
而且是重罚，
要么就甚至会把你的车直接拖走，
你可以看合同，
写得清清楚楚，
最终的结局就是你这边啊，
车钱两空，
所以说白了，
融资租令的话，
购物车人的身份啊，
它不是借款人，
而是乘租人，
车是以租令的形式，
而非贷款的形式，
而购物车人它所交的越贡，
其实也不是越贡，
它是租金，
而不是车代，
那么很多人就要问了，
说市面上到底哪些品牌，
走的是传统的车代，
哪些品牌又是走这个融资租令呢？
其实初步看下来啊，
很容易判断，
特斯拉的七年DC方案，
基本可以确定，
就是银行的直接贷款，
也就是银行的这个车代，
利率呢也相对比较透明，
比方说年化百分之零点九八到百分之二点九九，
也没有什么强制捆绑，
它这个就属于真正意义上的贷款购物车，
但是,
包括小米，
理想,
小鹏,
甚至后来跟进的像什么吉利银河啊，
蓝图啊，
东风一派，
我看了一下，
那么基本上都是融资租令，
你没有听错啊，
就是融资租令，
大多数是通过类似于，
像平安租令啊，
石桥啊，
一星金融啊，
或者是很多车企自家的金融公司，
或者叫做融资租令公司，
他们来进行操作的，
那么有的人可能会说了，
融资租令就融资租令呗，
反正便宜就行了，
是吧，好，
那么接下来呢，
我就跟大家来讲一讲啊，
就是如果选择融资租令的方案，
那么对你来说，
到底有哪些风险，
我们展开来讲一讲啊，
那么首先融资租令的车辆，
一般啊，
它会强制要求在店内去买全血，
那么可能有人会说了，
说我是租车啊，
这行手证、登记证书都不是我的名字，
那保险不应该是它卖吗？
从法律意义上来讲，
融资租令公司，
是这个车的车主对吧，
是所有人、所有方，
它是有义务确保车辆投保的，
但是确保车辆投保，
和谁去付保险的钱，
这是两个概念，
你想一想，
你就是正常是日租车，
对吧,
上了一些平台去租车，
那人家也会问你，
你是投这个基础的保险呢，
还是去买一个全血呢？
有的时候可能租车它本身就不贵，
不赚你的钱，
但是保险它是要赚钱的，
所以说这个全血你要是不接受，
好可以，
那你就不要买，
但是如果说你签了合同，
你接受了，
你不是说第一年，
说我买个全血，
第二年我找找关系，
我去到外面买，
不是的，
从这一年开始，
后面的七年，
你都得按照它的要求，
因为车不是你的，
是融资租赁公司的，
但是你签了合同，
你必须按要求，
年年买全血，
所以你后面你要如果，
比方说你开个特斯拉的Model 1，
你去问其他的Model 1的车主，
你说你第二年蓄保，
蓄了多少钱啊？
你车主说我蓄了五千多，
你一看你的全血，
你说第二年蓄了七千多，
你就问那个融资租赁，
你说怎么回事啊？
你问客服，
我为什么比别人贵两千块啊？
对不起，
必须电理全血购买，
合同里面写的精静主主，
对吧,
你要如果有质疑，
你可以找相关部门去投诉，
那投诉人家合法合理啊，
对不对，
你说啊，
你没给我反点，
那对不起，
反点是不合理的，
所以你这个，
没地方说理，
你每一年都要多交这个钱，
你比方说，
还是以这个小米预期为例，
如果是走七年DC方案，
那么首先你的合同，
就是要跟上海小米，
融资租赁公司去签，
还有一家啊，
也是小米指定的，
叫上海畅途，
融资租领有限公司，
就跟这两家其中一家去签，
它的年化费率大概是1%，
折合利率的话，
应该是在1.93%，
84期,
那么在还完之前，
肯定是行使证登记证述，
都是融资租领公司的嘛，
对吧,
那么小米预期的标准买，
它的第一年的保费，
如果按照它的要求来，
是投多少钱呢，
要投8，818.99元，
这是我在网上看到的，
真实的一个数字，
那么如果说，
不去走这个DC方案，
你正常买，
你去买保险的话是多少呢，
正常的话，
车损三折三折三百万，
在这个标准版的话，
一般情况下，
在6000多7000块钱那样子，
6000-7000,。
那么6000-7000和8000多8118,。
中间差了多少，
差了1000多，
将近2000块钱，
所以说，
你每一年多花这么多，
7年时间相当于多花了多少，
都花了1万多，
但这个钱说实话，
也不是融资租领公司赚的钱，
它只不过为了把自己的风险，
降到最低，
所以必须要求你去买全钱，
所以你能不能接受，
那么除此之外还有什么呢，
还有就是融资租领的车辆，
要去收取GPS的安装费，
因为它默认你是没有什么信用的，
它是默认这个车辆，
万一要是将来你还不上款，
对吧,
那我要把这个车辆追回，
那鬼知道你把车子藏到什么地方去了，
是吧,
你把这车子万一要是在专手卖掉了，
我要追究你法律责任的嘛，
那么GPS的安装费一般情况下，
从500到2000上下不等，
因为看它具体装什么样的GPS，
装多少个GPS，
那它也不会告诉你嘛，
安装的过程那都是黑箱操作的，
那肯定不能让你知道GPS装在什么地方，
是不是，
那么今后等你还清了84期的贷款，
还有包括有两个费用，
一个是解压一个过户的费用，
也是要你来支付的，
那么到时候还有一个问题啊，
你车上这么多的GPS，
你还把它拆下来呢，
你都不知道这些GPS装在什么地方，
你只有最早给这个车装GPS的这个，
相关的这个这个应该怎么讲的，
就是部门嘛，
只有他们才能去找到这些点，
再帮你进行去拆，
拆你认为是免费的吗，
也不是免费的呀，
还要再去付个钱，
那么不仅如此，
中途如果说这个车辆，
你想要个性一点去改个色，
对吧，改个色，
那么对不起，
你去车馆所是不是要备案啊，
你备案是不是要去借用它的这个车辆登记证书，
那对不起，
掏钱,
多少钱呢，
120元一次，
就是你去备案啊，
你要去跟它去，
因为不是你的车嘛，
去借这个登记证书120块钱一次，
那么如果你说我还要很着急，
因为既也不是说你上午去，
说把登记证书给我，
他上午就给你，
他还要再去什么申请流程，
你鬼知道三天四天五天能出的来，
那么你要加急，
额外再收你50块钱，
虽然说这些钱都不是特别多，
但是你会失踪什么感觉，
这感觉，
这感觉这不是进到自己家里，
就你每次坐在这车里，
就感觉是在借别人的车，
租别人的车，
那么实际上你确实也是在租别人的车嘛，
那么可能有朋友就要问了，
说那我怎么去判断，
我现在去买的这个车型，
他到底给我提供的七年DC贷款是传统车贷，
还是融资租令呢？
那么主要方法有三种，
首先就是你看他的合同标题，
是否含融资租令，
或者是售后回租，
相关的这些字眼，
如果是有，
那就不用说肯定是融资租令嘛，
对吧,
那么其次你就是问清楚，
上牌到底上谁的名字，
我相信这一点销售是不敢扯谎的，
他说上牌上你的名字，
结果上的不是你的名字，
那你最好是什么，
写在合同上面，
如果说他不写在合同上面，
你要知道现在有一些销售，
胆子非常的大，
他嘴上说啊没关系的，
最后的行者证登记证都是写你的名字，
但是等你把合同一签完，
你就发现完全不是这样，
所以合同是最关键的，
每一个合同上要签字的地方，
一定要把前前后后，
每一个字看看清清楚楚，
正面还有反面哦，
反面一定要看得清清楚楚，
最后的最后是什么，
就是你要问，
上牌之后车辆登记认输，
就是那个大的绿本，
到底谁来保管，
如果上牌，
必须是他指定的公司名，
而且绿本七年之后才能给你，
或者说这个绿本就车辆登记认输，
是由金融公司去保管，
他如果在这个合同里面是这么写的，
或者是销售跟你这么讲，
那么铁定百分之百，
就是融资租令，
所以听到这儿，
那么大家应该就明白了，
就是七年DC贷款，
他到底是怎么样的一个套路，
对吧,
那么现在你对这个方案，
还感兴趣吗？
那么可能有人要问，
那为什么在这个时间点，
突然就出现了这么多的品牌，
推出七年的DC方案呢？
其实很简单的道理嘛，
价格战打了这么久了，
嗓子都喊哑了，
现在大家已经前履计穷了，
2026年补贴又开始滑坡，
就实在没有什么好的刺激的，
这种手段来让大家消费了嘛，
今年1月份，
整个车市可以说是相当惨烈，
注意我用的是惨烈，
不是惨淡，
那么2月份正好是要过年，
所以我估计2月份大概率，
就不会去做什么，
1月份的销量统计什么的，
如果有一些没有眼力镜的，
这些自媒体，
他偏要去统计，
那这个确实你去看，
肯定非常难看，
但是我相信官方渠道，
应该大家就形成默契了，
就你不说我不说，
大家都不讲，
2月份不会公布，
1月份的销量成绩的，
太差了，
那么到了3月份，
可能就忍一忍嘛，
忍一忍到了3月底，
那就不行，
就一次性把123月份，
就公布一个一季度的销量成绩吧，
那最后就是还是嘛，
跟领导汇报的时候，
那就是一些像好嘛，
文中像好嘛，
大概就是这样子，
所以1月份真的是非常非常的惨烈，
那么在这个时间点上，
特斯拉突然发起了一个七年DC，
其实某种意义上讲，
他就是金融战嘛，
他就是在打金融战，
他就是用未来几年的利息和他的利润，
割肉去换量，
他本质上玩的是什么，
就是时间和杠杆的游戏，
我曾经讲过，
我说年轻人不要给自己加杠杆，
现在我想讲一句，
就中年人也不要加杠杆，
有些人觉得说，
人到中年对吧，
总共要对自己好一点，
银行有些存款，
然后我加点杠杆，
我去买点什么车啊，
这个啥的，
其实你要知道啊，
就中年人抵离风险的能力，
有的时候，
甚至还没有年轻人那么强，
年轻人说白了，
光脚的不怕穿鞋子，
真的实在是还不起了，
从头再来嘛，
他有的是时间啊，
但中年人缺的就是时间，
你没有时间了，
你经历不起失败，
一旦要是失败了你，
你再一转也马上就50了，
人过50,
你还当真是60岁是，
应该闯到的年纪啊，
就不是人和人不一样嘛，
有的人60岁真是闯到的时机啊，
你不是啊，
我也不是，
而且在我看来，
像特斯拉他发起金融站的时间点，
应该是内部啊，
精确算我的，
就起码他大概知道，
在这个时间点上，
国家的相关的政策，
是怎样怎样去往回缩，
对吧,
然后呢，
更加车企的价格站，
他肯定也是每天都瞄着嘛，
你说特斯拉跟不跟价格站，
他也跟，
但是跟的不是那么的紧，
特斯拉这几年的价格，
互上互下的，
他玩的是一种心理和营销的手法，
而不是说我偏要跟着别人的节奏，
别人降我就降，
特斯拉不是这么玩的，
特斯拉是我根据我自己的节奏，
我该涨一万涨一万，
我该降我就降，
然后降的时候你会觉得说，
哎,
好像我比前面的人买的划算，
然后他涨的时候呢，
又会给你一点新鲜感，
要么就是新款小改款，
要么就是再给你增加一点，
其他的一些相关的这个选装权益啊，
之类的，
反正不管怎么说，
涨涨跌跌，
感觉骂他的人很少，
以前还有人骂特斯拉背似，
这么多年，
你看现在，
还有人骂特斯拉背似吗？
你可以说他保守，
你也可以说特斯拉现在的整体销量，
也在往下滑，
但是26年特斯拉的第一枪，
我觉得他是精准算过的，
就是看你们这些，
国产汽车品牌，
互相厮杀，
互相打价格战，
现在都打累了吧，
现在都精疲力尽了吧，
现在都刺激不了买家了吧，
中国的消费者现在也都看了，
对吧,
退波啊，
这个补贴退波，
然后呢，
你们现在也卷不动了，
好,
我来刺激一波，
我直接放出个7年的，
这个DC贷款，
而且是这28年的银行DC啊，
你们来跟啊，
结果一个个跟的都是什么，
什么东西啊，
跟的都是融资租令，
你有本事跟特斯拉一样啊，
你也给消费者提供的是银行正常贷款啊，
我估猜啊，
后期可能会有一些，
它会调整过来，
就比方说之前我刚刚讲的，
像什么小米啊，
理想啊，小棚啊，
它提供的不都是融资租令吗，
现在媒体还没有大规模的报道，
我应该算是报道比较早了，
你麻后面你看，
如果持续报道，
然后呢，
这个车主也施压，
媒体也施压，
大家都在去讲这里面的套路，
很有可能有一些，
就可能真的就跟特斯拉一样，
就不就，
无非这成本的问题嘛，
有摇摇牙找银行，
就正常做七年期的这个银行的贷款，
所以说你不要着急，
你不要着急，
你一旦要是签了这个合同，
走融资租令方案，
你再想改你改不回来的，
所以你可以再等一等，
今年百分之百是等等党的胜利，
所以我感觉特斯拉的这一枪，
其实就是想在这个时间点，
来收割战场，
并不是说，
这是战争的终局啊，
只是这场战役，
在了这个时间点，
他想去先收割一波，
能抢多少市场分额，
就抢多少，
因为毕竟就往前推半年的话，
特斯拉的销量是在下滑的嘛，
对不对，
所以这一枪应该说，
暴击了很多的国产品牌，
不幸大家可以回头看，
一二三这三个月，
可能很多的车企，
销量数据不好看，
但特斯拉的销量数据，
我觉得真的是，
应该可能会非常夸张啊，
大家可以回头看一眼啊，
所以我前面说的，
特斯拉他用的是传统的银行的这个车样贷款，
那么其他家匆忙跟进，
用的是融资租令的套路，
那么小米、理想、小鹏这些车企，
他们匆匆忙忙去应对的，
要用融资租令这样的方式的，
他主要考虑就是成本，
还有包括他的风险，
相对来讲比银行这个传统贷款都要小很多，
但是特斯拉这个七年低率率的贷款，
他也有一个门槛，
就是银行正统的这个贷款啊，
他对你的个人信用，
要求是比较高的，
传统的车贷都存在这个问题，
就是个人的真性要求比较高，
但是所谓要求比较高，
以前我记得我做汽车销售的时候，
还分为大鱼漆跟小鱼漆，
还分为什么一加一二加二，
就是意思你如果是贷款鱼漆一天，
然后连续有过两次，
那么就是一加二，
贷款鱼漆一天有过一次，
就是一加一大概是这么个意思，
小鱼漆就是指正常的新用卡的这种，
可能忘了还了有那么一两次，
这个都可以去理解，
正常做贷款也不影响，
但是大鱼漆是指房贷，
房贷的兄弟们可千万不要鱼漆啊，
房贷鱼漆在你后面去贷款买任何一样东西，
去做贷款的时候都非常非常的敏感，
特别是你如果连续的房贷鱼漆，
那这个叫大鱼漆，
而且连续鱼漆，
那你的个人真心会非常的差，
个人真心差主要有两种可能性，
第一个就是贷款批不下来嘛，
对吧就非常差的，
第二个就是你可能贷款的额度，
就批不了那么高了，
就比方说你原来可以做15%的首富，
那对不起能给你贷，
但是你的首富要提升到30%，
甚至要提到50%，
贷款的份额会比较少一点，
所以这个个人信用是非常重要的啊，
那么怎么讲呢，
你要如果是走特斯拉的这个银行贷款，
那必须是要能符合他的个人真性，
但是你要如果是走融资租令，
融资租令说白了就是公司和个人去签，
他跟银行其实是两套系统，
那么这样一来说白了，
就是他只要想做你这个生意，
他觉得说他有这种封控能力，
你咋吧就是还不上，
反正你抵押贷款嘛，
首先这个车我收回来，
其次再看一看有没有从其他的渠道。
能够再从你身上压榨一点的，
所以他的这种，
怎么讲呢就追债的能力，
他跟银行，
他不一定是按同一个套路来，
说白了这个按什么套路具体，
有经历过的可以评论区讲一下，
有些我怕这个节目当中这个内容不太能说，
说了到这儿被被下架就不合适了，
对吧,
辛辛苦苦录那么久啊，
那么这种超长期的低利率本质上讲，
就是一个资产决策，
他给偷粮换住，
换那个概念，
变成了一个消费决策，
你买一辆30万左右的车，
你是不是要下很大的决心啊，
我们讲如果说，
你的年收入可能就是十来万块钱，
或者说你的银行存款，
就是差不多十几万吧，
你去买一个30来万的车，
你银行存款就十来万，
你肯定是要下很大的决心，
或者说你直接就放弃了，
这不是我考虑的东西啊，
但是如果你要冲一个视频会员，
你想看最后那几集或者是超前点播，
那你可能随手就开通了，
这没多少钱啊，
一个月十来块钱，
那么现在好了，
30来万的车，
20多万的车，
它现在变成了一个四五万的首付款，
那么原来是五六千一个月的月供，
现在变成了两千多块钱，
那么你再去看一看你的银行存款十来万，
再去看一看你的月收入可能八九千万八块钱，
那么你就会考虑说，
我拿出我一半的银行存款五万块钱，
我就能付这个首付，
我再拿出我不到一半的工资，
对不对，两三千嘛，
你工资八九千一万块，
就是不到一半，
我去付这个月供，
那么二三十万这么个新车，
不就开上了吗，
所以这叫什么呀，
这叫做钱包的厚度，
跟不上想法的高度，
这就是超前消费，
这就是把资产决策，
偷换成消费决策的一个典型案例，
但是我想讲，
兄弟们，
新能源车是不是现在越来越像电子设备，
大家看一看自己手上的手机，
你手机一般多久换一次，
一年，两年，
还是三年，
我手上用的是iPhone 13 Pro，
我都记不得这个手机买了多少年了，
反正电池去年不太行了，
我还找了一个我们一个朋友推荐的，
去换一个电池，
就换了两百块钱吧，
现在这个电池据换很好，
整个的机器的性能也完全够用，
所以iPhone 13 Pro对于我来讲真的，
也不能说完全没有吸引力吧，
就是换也可以，
但是不换也没有任何问题，
以前还觉得说，
这是个生产工具，
我平时还会用评工手机去拍拍视频，
但是现在看来的话，
也没有那么多用手机拍视频的机会，
基本上我出门都会带摄影师，
就算没有摄影师如果是一镜到底，
我还有运动相机呢，
我还有OSMO Pocket 3呢,。
很多东西都可以拍，
我不一定要用手机拍，
所以手机其实更多的，
不就是平时去登录登录我们的智慧星球，
微博,
还有去看一看什么叮叮微信，
刷刷这些相关信息，
就这么多，
其他没什么用处，
所以我就想问，
你的手机多久换一次，
你每次换真的是刚需吗，
还是说某一个功能点，
其实用的并不多，
但是挺诱惑你的，
所以就这么一次级，
你就把这个手机给买了，
那你买手机有没有贷款啊，
有没有分期啊，
那当然有人要说了，
汽车比手机要贵得多，
换车周期它会更长一些，
好,
那么你就看看周围第一批去买新能源车的人，
这一波人他们的换车的速度，
大概是几年，
他们的换车周期是三年，
四年还是五年，
有没有七年以上换的，
对吧,
而随着新能源车的电池技术升级，
还有包括智商智价的迭代升级，
那么你今天觉得这个车哪哪都好，
那么可能一年之后，
你就觉得这个技术是不是有点落后了，
两年之后，
你就开始觉得说，
我看它是不是个老古董啊，
三年四年，
你可能就忍不住了，
你要换车啦，
这还没完啊，
汽车是典型的消费品，
从你提升的那一刻，
就在贬值，
那么当你还了四五年的所谓的车贷，
其实不是车贷，
是融资租令的那个，
还了四五年之后，
你会发现，
就是你今后如果再还这两年的所谓的贷款，
余额,
这个钱，
它可能超过了你车的实际残值啊，
是不是，
那么你舍上这台车，
它不就变成那个负资产了吗？
它是不是就负资产，
就是你车也不值钱，
但是占还没还完，
而且这还没完啊，
这里面万一要是车辆再出一些什么大的事故，
或者说，
如果个人啊，
出现了一些资金上的问题，
那么这个车辆你要把它卖掉，
可能会出现个什么情况啊，
叫做资不抵债，
就是你车辆卖掉的钱，
还抵不上你后面这两年，
或者是可能剩下来个二十七多少七的，
总的还款额，
你还要再补钱给它，
你把车卖了，
你还要补钱给它，
你说夸张不夸张，
而且人生有多少个七年，
大家想一想，
七年啊，
你可以从单身一个人，
变成夫妻两个人，
再变成一家三口，
你可能从小职员，
变成小领导，
然后再变成CEO啊，
不是,
再被公司降薪，
再被公司裁员，
那么如果说家里面，
有老人，
那万一，
这个老人在生病住个院，
好好骂，
家里面啊，
奥奥代补的这个小婴儿，
然后呢，
没有工作的老婆，
医院里面躺在床上的爹娘，
七年前你是一人吃饱全家不熟，
有个那个八千九千万八块钱的工资，
你说两千多的月供，
那毫无压力，
那现在呢，
就算收入不便，
如果遇到我刚刚提到这种情况，
结了婚，
娶了一个老婆，
老婆生了个孩子，
那没工作，
让孩子要吃饭，
老婆要花钱，
如果万一要是父母，
哪怕就是其中有一位，
身体不太好，
一旦要是住了院，
那么你靠什么来支撑？
你是家里面的顶梁柱啊，
所以说你这两千块钱的月供，
以前对你来讲，
可能是没多少钱，
但是现在呢，
如果到了这种环境下，
他就像一座山一样，
压在你的头上，
你是甩也甩不掉啊，
你要知道这个车，
毕竟他不是在你的名下，
你真的要把它卖掉的话，
你要看合同，
他是怎么约定的，
所以这个时候，
就会遇到个非常麻烦的事情，
我觉得钱倒不是什么最重要的，
最重要就是，
当你的整个的大环境，
经济环境和家庭的这个压力变大，
环境变得越来越差，
你越胆小，
你就越害怕变化，
你越怕变化，
你就越抓不住机遇，
对吧,
钱趴了后怕虎，
明明有个好的机会，
兄弟们想拉你一把去一个新公司，
你就是担心啊，
你担心你的这个贷款还不上啊，
那么最后，
你的人生就被锁死在某个公司的格子间里面，
对吧,
你再也出不去了嘛，
因为连零一过，
你也没什么动力了嘛，
就这样吧，
是吧,
我可能说的有些严重了，
但是你看，
网上天天在传，
这个菲菲洋洋什么美国的斩杀线，
哪个国家都有，
说句实在话，
而且这个，
我也不想多说了，
对吧,
那那那，
你个人有个人的理解嘛，
对吧,
那不就是一样的逻辑嘛，
还还相扣，
说到底，
应对人生变故，
很多人他缺乏财富弹性，
欲望太多，
他反而会给自己套上一层，
加上一层枷锁，
那么怎么看这个7年的低利率贷款呢，
其实我也不知道该怎么去评价这个7年期的低利率贷款，
它合法合规，
厂家也是真的贴了钱，
但是除了特斯拉是真的传统银行贷款，
其他的都是，
不能说都吧，
就基本上都是融资租赁，
风险实际上还是转价给消费者，
关键是很多人他根本就不懂这些，
而且这还会形成一个非常坏的风气，
什么意思呢，
就是同样一款，
比方说二十多万的车，
那么A品牌说，
首付三四万，
月供一千八，
那么B品牌说，
我们家首付五六万，
月供三千五，
你说消费者他用脚投票会选谁，
那么客户自然而然，
是不是就被那些提供低月供的，
低首付的品牌给勾走了，
那么没有低月供低首付的，
难道说这个车不行吗？
难道说这个品牌不行吗？
但实际上它就卖不出去，
卖不出去，
惊心慌伤，
它就会失去信心，
甚至会关门大吉，
这里面的连锁反应其实是非常负面的，
那么对于一些规模比较小，
财务状况又不好的企业来讲，
那么这就是进一步，
万丈深渊，
退一步，
粉身碎骨，
所以节目最后呢，
给大家点建议啊，
我主要是想讲四点，
首先就是，
新年期这个低利率贷款，
在我看来它不是什么福利，
它就是诱惑你去透支未来的，
你不要去看自己能不能买得起，
而是要去看它总费用支出，
加上它的车辆折旧，
不是一共七年吗？
七年的折旧，
其实通过网上很多的计算器是能算得出来的，
你去平衡一下，
你真实的用车成本，
首富低，
月供低，
这是为什么呀？
是用时间换过来的，
你总成本其实并没有少多少，
利息该有还是有，
虽然厂家贴了，
但你也是有的，
二十多万的车，
它仍然是二十多万的车，
它没有变成十几万，
这第一点，
你如果真的想买，
最后贷款期限，
和这个车辆的核心价值，
它的周期要相匹配，
什么意思呢？
就如果说你曾经买过车，
你就要仔细思考一下，
你下一辆车准备开几年再换，
那么如果说你是三五年就必定换车的人，
那么你想想看七年期的贷款，
它就算利率再低，
它适不适合你呢？
你如果说我无所谓，
冰箱踩电大沙发我都不要，
只要是个电车，
只要电池不换，
哪怕续航缩减个百分之三十，
我也正常开，
我咬着牙，
我要把这个七年给开完，ok，
那有可能这个七年期贷款，
是比较适合你的，
那么如果你要提前还款，
一定一定要看清楚，
提前还款，
这个合同里面是怎么约定的，
那么再就是，
你要了解银行传统的这个贷款，
和这个融资租令之间的差异，
你不要说买完之后你才知道，
哦,
这个车辆的归属权不是属于我的，
诶?
习主任上面怎么不是我的名字呀？
等于认出怎么不是我的名字呀？
买完之后，
你缓然大悟已经没有用了，
你不要说，
想当然的以为，
啊,
这个啊，
融资租令也无所谓，
对吧,
融资租令，
余期将来我，
呃,
持个一两天还，
无所谓，
反正宽限期嘛，
对吧,
我以前我带过款，
我知道，
但是我告诉你，
不是这样的，
融资租令是不会给你什么宽限期的，
哪怕融资租令的，
这个余期于一天，
你会收取高额的乏息，
甚至会直接车被拖折，
因为有GPS，
你可能下班到停车场一看车没了，
为什么呀，
你没到期还钱啊，
对不对，
而且我告诉你，
拖完车之后，
你已经付的租金不退了，
因为你是违约，
然后车辆进行拍卖，
车辆拍卖完之后，
如果是，
呃,
资不抵载，
就是不足以抵还你后面的这个啊，
这个叫什么，
就是月供啊，
或者是什么的，
因为你应该是租金嘛，
那么你还需要再去补差额，
所以兄弟们，
一定一定要去看清楚，
这个相关的合同啊，
最后就是提醒大家，
还是那句老话，
回归消费的本质嘛，
大家都知道，
你看那个六大国有银行，
已经下架了五年期大额存单，
什么意思啊，
那名眼人一看就明白了，
就是鼓励老百姓去消费啊，
拿什么消费啊，
你有钱消费吗，
没钱没关系，
贷款给你嘛，
是不是，
所以肯定有很多人他，
抵挡不住这样的诱惑，
周围人长期会有一个什么样的状态呢，
就是换车，
换手机，
换各种时髦的电子产品，
这个将来肯定是常态，
新常态嘛，
对吧,
那国人又喜欢对比，
也不问这个东西，
适不适合自己，
反正就是，
别人有，
我必须得有，
人我有，
人有我心嘛，
对吧,
所以道理呢，
大家都懂，
大环境不好，
不稳定因素很多，
要开源节流，
要增加被动收入，
要多搞钱，
但是真正到了那一刻，
在什么短视频平台啊，
在什么图文平台啊，
刷到了一些，
什么电子产品的测评啊，
广告宣传啊，
海报啊，
对不对，
你包括我做汽车评论呢，
有的时候我也会测一些电子产品，
那有的时候再给大家种种草，
有些也确实是广告嘛，
对吧,
那么很多人他就，
他就是被诱惑了嘛，
所以,
我虽然是吃这碗饭的，
但我也想告诉你，
你一定要有这个定理，
一定要想清楚，
什么是刚需消费，
不要乱消费啊，
兄弟们，
道理虽然说大家都懂，
但是,
我想让你去花，
必要的钱，
不要花，
那些很浮夸，
很没必要的钱，
没有用，
说句实在话，
真的没有用，
因为每个人，
他的性格，
他的这个三观，
他的环境，
他的认知，
他都不一样，
所以这些道理呢，
人人都懂，
人人都会讲，
但是真正做起来呢，
那就完全不一样，
就像很多人也讲我，
说三道理怎么这么摳啊，
你给刀扫就买个风田的混洞，
平时看你买个什么东西，
还纠结再三，
我为什么纠结，
其实不是说我买不起，
而是我在考虑，
他到底有必要，
还是没必要，
对吧,
他有没有可以平替的，
那么他如果说是生产工具，
他是需要长期使用的，
那我肯定是选择，
可能是这个品类当中，
最顶流的最好的，
最顶级的牌子，
只要是我能消费得起，
是吧,
所以金流座基本上，
就是这样那个消费的风格，
很多人理解我，
大家也有人不太理解我，
就是说我扣门，
那我相信不少人，
应该也看过，
霍花德马克思写的一本书，
叫投资最重要的事，
非常有名啊，
这本书呢，
我不是看的，
我是听的，
听书的，
其中有一句话我觉得讲的非常好，
叫风险，
不在于市场下跌时投资，
而在于你不理解自己持有什么，
为何持有，
特别是在经济下行的时候，
我觉得这句话，
真的是深有感触，
虽然说他这句话，
更适合的是放在投资领域，
就比方说，
在市场波动的时候，
下行的区间里面，
可能你会产生不必要的恐慌，
去做出一些错误的决策，
但是,
你就是放在日常生活当中，
也是一样的道理啊，
对不对，
整体的经济下行，
市场环境不是特别的好，
那么某一些事物，
在你进行消费的时候，
那不是投资啊，
就是消费的时候，
你是不是能理解，
自己到底持有什么，
为什么去持有，
所以这句话我觉得，
还是送给我们的听友，
大家一起来，
抱团取暖，
一起来穿越寒冬，
等待春天的来临，
好吧,
那么以上呢，
就是本期节目所有的内容，
改大收听，
下面是留言互动环节，
那么每期节目呢，
留言区有我们抽取三位评论，
然后呢，
去赠送由认严计提供的，
玉露香梨，
试吃装，
每一盒里面有五颗玉露香梨，
非常的好吃，
那么大家如果是想要购买玉露香梨啊，
想要购买这个，
勤粹的苹果，
包括我们这个过年期间啊，
只在过年前，
去进行销售的黑珠露香肠，
都可以去在小程序，
搜索摆车全说，
或者联系我们的微信，
4641，5254就可以了，
那么小宇宙喜马拉雅，
大家呢，
如果没有订阅的，
可以去帮忙点击，
订阅一下，
都已经听到这了嘛，
对吧,
订阅一下，
每周三，
每周六更新，
或有提醒，
那么还有就是像喜马拉雅，
如果说你有月票的话，
可以帮忙给我的节目，
偷偷月票，
在那个播放页面的下方，
投送月票的话，
我的名次会更靠前一些，
感谢大家，
感谢,
好,
那么看一看上期节目的留言啊，
上期节目呢，
有一位听友叫做，
新秀访大潘哥，
他问了一个问题，
我觉得蛮典型的，
他说,
能不能去聊一聊，
二手电车购买的选题，
就比方说，
如何避坑啊，
像我手上现在有个燃油车，
车框其实挺好的，
但是卖呢，
又不止几万块钱，
不卖呢，
每年的油费，
又是个不小的开支，
但是我有感觉，
电车迭代很快，
有一些热门的车型，
可能车刚买到手，
很快就成就款了，
所以我就想着，
油车呢，
我就留着，
然后再买一个便宜的，
二手电车，
进行逮捕，
其实我觉得啊，
很多人都在算这笔账，
但这笔账算的根本就不对，
你油车卖了是不值钱，
但拿来用，
对吧,
它的折就相对来讲，
就相对比较小了嘛，
其实你每年只要是继续再开，
你的折就一定是，
非常非常小幅度的折就，
那么同时，
你说油费是不小的开支，
油费是不小的开支，
你每天开出门是在干嘛呀，
你是在赚钱的路上啊，
你是开的越多，
赚的越多啊，
你总不能说，
每天开个车子出去到处，
什么钓个鱼啊，
你就算干这个事，
那也是你的个人爱好，
那这个油费我觉得花的，
也是值的嘛，
所以这个油费啊，
你不要总是跟电费比，
我觉得啊，
你与其说，
为了省个油啊，
觉得卖这个油车不值钱，
你去买一辆电车，
电车买回来不一样贬值吗？
对不对，
你虽然说电费是省了，
但你那个油车不开，
它相当于就是为零，
它的价值为零，
是不是这个概念？
所以我觉得很多人，
你还,
你应该是做生意的，
叫紧绣房，
你是做生意的，
但你要如果问我说，
那二手电车怎么买相对比较合适？
我是觉得是这样的，
二手电车在市场上最杀瓜的，
逃车的方式，
就是选那种，
差不多在三年左右，
今年是2026年嘛，
其实我就按2025年年底来算，
就基本上是2022年，
2021年其实都可以考虑，
2023年就算比较新的了，
你去买一些，
就是非常这个，
鸣气大的，
保有量大的，
口碑稳定的，
而且最好是能查到它的完整的，
维修保养纪录，
包括保险的理赔纪录，
最好最好还能看到它的充电纪录，
你比如说这个人是有家用充电装的，
而且他的手机App里面也是能看到，
什么时间充了多少次电，
多少多电，
如果非常完整，
你看这个哥们，
就是每一天都在自己家的私人充电装上充电，
也不怎么跑长途，
两点一线上班，
下班带步，
车辆也从来没维修过，
也没撞过，
这种车的计时开三年，
我告诉你，
板板正正的，
哪怕就是比其他的，
同年份的二手车稍微贵一点，
都可以买，
像什么特斯拉猫豆三，
猫豆外，
就是二一年二二年都很便宜，
那么包括其他的像小鹏，
未来,
理想,
这些都可以考虑，
对吧,
还包括像什么极客，
零客都没问题，
其他的关于像车框方面，
就一句两句说不清了，
车框,
我觉得首先保底，
得有一份第三方的检测报告，
是吧,
那么至少要保证这个车辆，
没有出过大的事故，
没有水泡，
没有火烧，
那么其他的，
你担心的一些什么问题，
你就把它写在合同里面就可以了，
好吧,
那么这是第一位听友，
下面第二位听友叫做小丽强，
小丽强他说，
刀哥我给你分享两件事，
长城坦克400，
去年底在澳洲上市，
他的指导价跟国内是一致的，
用户实际上在澳洲的入手价格，
算下来的话，
比国内还要便宜，
差不多六千块钱，
我大概知道这个事，
就是,
他在当地是送保养，
然后好像是六年的保养都是免费的，
还有包括这个整车的这个质保，
好像比国内都要长，
他说结果这个事情传到国内，
国内的媒体，
包括车主各种批评，
那么实际上澳洲啊，
它是进口关税基本上都没有，
因为澳洲国内已经没有整车工厂了，
所以在这个地方呢，
国产新能源竞争也非常的激烈，
也很绝，
他说这是第一件事，
第二件事是什么呢，
就是关于设计方案，
说车企老板拍板这件事情，
其实不仅仅是国内的车企，
国外车企也是一样的，
之前听国外的车企华裔的设计师们他们聊天，
当年BMW宝马的七戏，
不是说那个超大嘴的设计方案很丑吗？
其实这个设计方案，
是这个宝马的董事会拍板确认的，
实际上设计部门是提供了三款设计方案，
没想到最后董事会拍板的那个方案，
是设计团队彻底放开思想，
凑数的那个方案，
结果就是全球的新七戏，
销量大悲剧，
然后被S级打的脸都重了，
这个我觉得是非常野路自的一个消息吧，
一个这么大的国际化的公司，
设计团队还把凑数的方案也一起包上去，
我还真的不太敢相信啊，
这也太草台班子了吧，
宝马毕竟也是全球国际型的这种大公司啊，
但是话又说回来，
你别说宝马这样的公司了，
你就算是某些国家，
对吧现在这两年的新闻报道里面，
它也是个草台班子啊，
那做的事情简直是让人感觉有匪夷所思啊，
所以全世界都是个草台班子，
这句话我觉得真的是太精准了啊，
那么下面有一位听友叫做AS123，
他说，哎刀哥我想问一下，
车身电池一体报废这个事你知道吗？
那是不是就意味着将来如果电池坏了，
那么只能换车了，不能换电池了？
我这个理解对吗？
也就是说无论将来电池多便宜，
还是多么的好，
你都不能换电池，
是这样的吗？
那当然不是这样的了，
车电一体报废，
前几天就上了热搜了，
这个问题其实问得很好，
很多人其实也想问，
就是到底是怎么回事，
它其实，
它的完整说法是今年4月1号起，
即将实施新能源汽车废旧动力电池回收和综合利用管理暂行办法，
核心就是一句话，
就是非换电模式的新能源汽车在报废的时候，
必须将整车包含原装动力电池，
一并交给就是有资质的报废机动车回收拆解企业，
让他们来进行拆解，
严禁私自拆解，
严禁出售，
或者是丢弃动力电池，
什么意思呢？
说白了就是，
回收企业，
它要把这个电池上的有一个唯一的编码，
24位的,
这个24位就是电池的身份证，
要把它跟国家动力电池的这个溯源管理平台信息匹配之后，
才可以接收，
要不然这个，
就是新能源车你报废不了，
所以简单的讲就是，
车电一体报废，
不会像以前那样，
就是说只报废车身，
那么电池你可以私自拆下来，
其实也是违规的，
但是以前没那么严，
很多的人就是报废一个空壳子嘛，
电池拆下来就把它卖掉，
那么这里面就导致几个问题是需要去管的，
第一个问题就是，
很多这个报废的新能源车拆下来的电池，
它流入到市场，
但是它拆又不是按照正常流程拆，
它是暴力拆解，
那么这个电池的稳定性就很差，
那么流到什么地方上去呢？
流到一些就大家俗称的老头乐，
就低速电动车，
还有一些这种两轮车上，
也是用理电池的嘛，
所以它就非常容易引发自然，
正规的两轮车不会用的，
正规的老头乐，
相对正规的吧，
一般也不太敢用，
所以它路子比较野的，
这种什么杂牌的拼装的，
它就敢用，
那么第二个呢，
就是它的拆解过程，
很容易引发环境污染，
因为这不是一辆两辆的产，
它已经形成一个产业链了嘛，
那么第三个就是本身涅鼓猛，
我们知道三媒体电池嘛，
涅鼓猛，
它正规的回收是可以材料再生利用的，
利用率比较高，
但是你想这种的话，
那基本上就不存在什么回收再利用啊，
对吧,
那么2030年，
中国退役的动力电池。
预计要超过100万吨，
非常大的一个数量级啊，
100万吨,
所以从现在开始，
相关部门其实就是在做这种叫。
提前的避缓管理，
整个的避缓管理，
基本上就是这样，
所以呢，
今天咱们就聊那么多啊，
然后以上三位呢，
就是我们的重奖厅友，
大家去跟我们的盾牌联系领奖，
就可以了，
盾牌的微信是46415254，
那么希望这期节目对于很多，
对于七年期的这个DC贷款方案，
不是很了解的朋友，
能够有所帮助，
如果说你身边的人最近要买车，
他也问了你这个什么七年期地利率，
DC到底是怎么回事，
你可以把我的这期节目退给他们，
我觉得这期节目对他来讲，
应该是会很有帮助，
至少是可以帮他逼掉很多的坑，
对吧,
那么如果想关注我更多的内容呢，
在Bilibili,。
可以搜索摆车片说，
我每周五有更新，
也可以在短人评平台，
比方说抖音啊，
快手啊，
视频号啊，
小红书啊，
搜索,
三刀,
砍车,
单人旁，
砍大山的砍，
还有我的个人微博叫摆车全说三刀，
那么同时呢，
大家如果说想加入我们的社群，
也可以添加微信，
46415254,。
我们的公众号也叫摆车全说，
每天都会有更新原创文章，
那么如果说你要想了解最新的车试动态，
最新的价格行情，
可以关注一下我们的公众号，
那么想跟我一对一的交流，
可以关注我的知识星球，
其实在46415254的微信，
以及我们的公众号里面，
都可以找到我的知识星球，
在我们的节目的详情页面里面，
也有我的知识星球，
上知识星球，
我们一起来交流，
今天这期节目就到这里，
我们下一期，
接着聊，
拜拜!